♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE COMMUNIST FULL
COURSE PREP, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANKLE.
DURING THE NFL COLIN KAEPERNICK
KNEELING CONTROVERSY, PROMINENT
NBA PLAYERS CAME TO HIS DEFENSE
AND SUPPORTED HIS EFFORTS.
THE NBA ALSO SUPPORTED THE
GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS IN 2018
WHEN THE LEAGUE JAMS ANNOUNCED
THEY WOULD MAKE THE CEREMONIAL
TRIP TO THE WHITE HOUSE AS LONG
AS TRUMP WAS AN OFFENSE.
>> POLITICS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN A
PART OF THE PLAYERS LIFE, AND IN
FACT THIS LEAD, OUR OWNERS FEEL
COMFORTABLE EXPOSING THEIR
POLITICAL POINT OF IO.
>> Laura: WE LEARNED OVER THE
WEEKEND, THE MBS A OF FREE
EXPRESSION HAS ITS LIMITS.
OF THE FIRE STORM FRIDAY WHEN
HOUSTON ROCKET GENERAL MANAGER
TWEETED THIS.
WHEN HE FOR FREEDOM, STAND WITH
HONG KONG."
THIS DREW THE IRE OF THE CHINESE
COMMUNIST REGIME.
IT HAD TO NBA WHERE IT REALLY
HURTS.
THE POCKETBOOK.
SPENDING MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
WORTH OF BUSINESS, BEIJING
BANNED THE HOUSTON ROCKETS GAMES
FROM CHINESE TV.
ROCKETS OMER IN THE MBA GOT THE
MESSAGE AND QUICKLY GROVELED TO
THE CHINESE MASTERS.
MOVING TO CENTER HIS TWEETS.
ROCKET PLAYER JAMES HARDEN WAS
IN TOKYO FOR A TEAM PRACTICE, IT
BEGS THE FOR FORGIVENESS.
>> YOU KNOW, WE LOVE CHINA, WE
LOVE PLAYING THERE, AND WE
APPRECIATE THEM THE FAN BASE WE
LOVE EVERYTHING.
>> Laura: EVERYTHING THEY ARE
ABOUT.
WHO STOMACH DUTIFULLY OBEYED AND
DELETED THE PRO HONG KONG BOOK
ALL MY TWEETS.
IF HE EVEN ISSUED A APOLOGY, I
DID NOT INTEND BY A TO CAUSE ANY
OFFENSE TO ROCKET FANS OF MINE
IN CHINA.
I HOPE THAT THOSE WERE UPSET
WILL KNOW THE DEFENDING OR MISS
UNDER STOMACH MISUNDERSTANDING
WITHOUT MY ATTENTION.
THE MOST DESPICABLE REACTION
CAME FROM THE MBA ITSELF.
THE LEAGUE PUT OUT TO APOLOGIES.
ONE IN ENGLISH CALLING THE TWEET
REGRETTABLE AND ANOTHER
SHAMELESS STATEMENT AND CHINESE
READING THEY WERE EXTREMELY
DISAPPOINTED THE INAPPROPRIATE
MARKS MADE BY HOUSTON ROCKET
GENERAL MANAGER.
STANDING WITH THE PERSECUTED
PEOPLE OF HONG KONG IS
INAPPROPRIATE?
THEY SHOULD WEAR ANY CRITICISM
OF THE CHINESE REGIME AS A BADGE
OF HONOR, BUT NO CAN DO.
YOU KNOW, I ALSO THINK IT'S
FUNNY TO LOOK BACK 18 MONTHS OR
GO TO SELF-RIGHTEOUS POMPOUS
COMMENTS OF NBA COACHES WHO HAVE
NO TROUBLE TRASHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS VOTERS
WORRIED I THINK THE SPURS HAD TO
COACH, GREG POPOVICH.
>> I WONDER WHAT THE PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT WHO VOTED FOR HIM,
WHERE THEIR LINE IS.
WHERE IS THE MORALITY AND THE
DECENCY KICK IN, ONE WONDERS
WHAT IS IN THEIR HEAD.
THE COUNTRY IS AN EMBARRASSMENT
TO THE WORLD.
WE WANT NO, YOU'RE AN
EMBARRASSMENT, GREG, YOU HAVE
THE AUDACITY TO LECTURE US ON
MORALITY AT YOUR LEGAL?
STANDING WITH ONE OF THE MOST
REPRESSIVE REGIMES IN THE WORLD?
ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
DID HE SPEAK OUT TODAY AND
SUPPORT?
NO, I DON'T EXCEL.
STILL WAITING FOR THAT.
NO, SPEAKING TO PLAYERS OF
TRUMP'S, BUT WHEN THEY SAY A
BLANCHE PRETTY COULD COME UP
PRETTY BLAND CRITIQUE OF THEM
ONE OF THE MOST HORRIFIC
DICTATORSHIP, SUDDENLY THERE'S
CRICKETS CHIRPING EVERYWHERE.
>> IT'S A DIFFICULT TIME, WE ALL
KNOW THE SITUATION.
WE ALL KNOW WHY, WE ALL KNOW WHO
THE SOURCES.
A LOT OF THE DIVISION COMES FROM
BECAUSE IT IS SO OBVIOUS NOW,
IT'S BORING, THE BAR HAS BEEN
LOWERED SO FAR.
>> Laura: YEAH.
QUITE PATHETIC.
THE BAR SURE HAS BEEN LOWERED
WHEN THE NDA STANDS MORE
UNEQUIVOCALLY FOR THE HAMMER AND
SICKLE THAN IT DOES THE RED,
WHITE, AND BLUE.
OR IS IT JUST ALL ABOUT MONEY?
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE SAME
LEAGUE THAT MOVED IN 2017 NBA
ALL-STAR GAME OUT OF CHARLOTTE,
NORTH CAROLINA, OVER A STATE
THAT PRESENTED TRANSGENDER FROM
USING WHATEVER BATHROOMS THEY
WANTED TO.
APPARENTLY, THAT WAS TOO MUCH
FOR THE NBA, BUT CHINA?
STIFLING FREE SPEECH,
BRUTALIZING POLITICAL
DISSIDENTS, CHRISTIANS, MUSLIMS
THERE, REEDUCATION CAMPS,
APPARENTLY THAT'S ALL FINE.
WE LOVE WHAT THEY ARE ALL ABOUT.
IF THE NBA WANTED TO USE GAMES
AS A TOOL OF SOCIAL CHANGE,
WOULD IT NOT BE APPROPRIATE TO
CANCEL THE GAMES IN CHINA?
GIVEN THEIR HORRENDOUS HUMAN
RIGHTS RECORD?
THE PERSECUTION?
IMPRISONMENTS?
THE DISSIDENTS AND ANYONE REALLY
WHO SPEAKS THEIR CONSCIENCE AND
PERHAPS AGAINST THE BRUTAL
REGIME?
WOULD THAT BE A NICE CHANGE?
>> I NEVER IMAGINED THIS COULD
HAPPEN IN THE 21ST CENTURY.
INNOCENT PEOPLE SUBJECTED TO
TOPS ON THEIR HANDS, SHACKLED TO
COME UP LIKE HOODS OVER THEIR
HEADS.
>> EVERY DAY THEY TOSSES A
LITTLE BREAD AND WATER, AND
EVERY DAY THEY WOULD INTERROGATE
15 OR 20 OF US WITH UNBEARABLE
BRUTALITY.
>> Laura: AS LONG AS THE NBA
GETS ITS FRANCHISE FEES, OKAY BY
THEM.
THIS IS A BARBARIC REGIME.
THIS IS DICTATORSHIP CONTROLS
HOW MANY CHILDREN COUPLES COULD
HAVE FORCED STERILIZATION AND
ABORTION ON WOMEN.
ARE THOSE ENDANGERED LIVES
WORTHY OF A PROTEST OR JUST
SAYING, YOU KNOW, MONEY IS GOOD
BUT WE CANNOT DO IT ANYMORE.
OR REALLY CANCEL GAMES OVER
BATHROOM SIGNAGE CONTROVERSY.
THE MBA IS CLICKED OVER TO
SIGNAL WHEN IT COSTS THEM
NOTHING.
BUT THE MOMENT THERE CHINESE
OVERLORDS BULK, STATE
POWER IN THE WINTER.
CHECK OUT THE CRITICISM, CHINA'S
TREATMENT OF THE ROCKETS AS A
WARNING SHOT TO EVERY
PROFESSIONAL SPORTS TEAM AND ANY
AMERICAN BUSINESS DOING BUSINESS
IN CHINA.
PLAY BEAR THEIR ROLES OR YOU
WILL BE PUNISHED.
JUST TODAY, CHINA SCRUBBED ALL
SOCIAL MEDIA REFERENCES AND
ACCESS TO THE SHOW "SOUTH PARK"
IN THEIR COUNTRY.
THIS OF THE DAY AFTER THE SHOW
DARED TO CRITICIZE CHINA AND
PERTURB PROGRAMS.
♪ ♪
>> I AM A PROUD MEMBER OF THE
COMMUNIST PARTY.
THE PARTY IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE INDIVIDUAL.
>> Laura: WERE DIRECTION TO
THE FAN, ISSUED THIS MOCK
APOLOGY.
LIKE THE NBA, WE WELCOME THE
CHINESE CENTERS INTO OUR HOMES
AND INTO OUR HEARTS, WE LOVE
MONEY MORE THAN FEAR FREEDOM AND
DEMOCRACY.
SHE DOES NOT LOOK LIKE WE NEED
THE POOL AT ALL, THE GREAT
COMMUNIST PARTY OF CHINA, THIS
AUTUMN SARGON BOUNTY BE
HARVESTABLE.
WE GOOD NOW, CHINA?
"I STAND BY WHAT WE SAID BEFORE,
WE SHOULD GRADUALLY DISENTANGLE
AMERICAN INTERESTS FROM CHINESE
INTERESTS UNTIL THEY COMPLETELY
REFORM THEIR WAYS.
AMERICAN BRANDS, AMERICAN
COMPANIES ARE ENGAGED IN A
DEMONIC BARGAIN.
AN '80s, WHEN CAMPUS ACTIVISTS
PUSHED THE ENTIRE CAMPUS BECAUSE
OF OUR TO APARTHEID.
BANNERS HUNG OUT OF DORM WINDOWS
ALL OVER CAMPUS.
BUT IT WASN'T A LOT OF MONEY TO
BE MADE IN SOUTH AFRICA, NOT
REALLY.
AND THE VALUE OF BILLIONS IN
CHINA IS MORE IMPORTANT THE
PRECIOUS VALUE OF FREE
EXPRESSION IN THE NBA FREEZE
THEY CHERISHED?
NEXT TIME, THE TRITON FOR TWO
SINGLE CIVIL RIGHTS, WE ARE
GOING TO
ASK THEM WHY WHEN THEY HAD THE
CHANCE TO STAND FOR UNIVERSAL
VALUE OF FREE
SPEECH, FREE EXERCISE OF